JavaScript gives us specific
capabilities to perform any website
related task including design the front
end and working on the back end this is
just one of the numerous factors
contributing to javascript's appeal in
2022 research shows that JavaScript
stands among the world's top 10 most
widely used programming languages
if you want to know about the importance
of JavaScript try disabling it on your
browser and your web pages will not work
properly in fact sites like Facebook
Google Netflix and YouTube will not work
without JavaScript so hello everyone and
welcome to the simply on YouTube channel
I hope you guys are doing well today we
will be taking you through the
JavaScript full course we will cover
everything in this video from Basics to
advanced level topics don't worry if
you're a newbie or an advanced level
developer this video will help you in
different aspects so before we begin let
me tell you guys that we have regular
updates on multiple technology videos
so if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological friends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply
learning so let's go through the agenda
for this tutorial we'll start this video
by understanding what JavaScript is
where we will see how JavaScript came to
existence will also go through the
different reasons to learn JavaScript
following that we will cover basic
JavaScript topics like document object
model in JavaScript and vs code
installation we'll also create a hello
world program in JavaScript
next we will cover the fundamentals of
JavaScript including JavaScript
statements comments variables data types
type conversions and operators in
JavaScript then we will move on and
cover topics like control statements and
Loops in JavaScript
both topics have the outmost importance
when it comes to any programming
language once we are done with the basic
topic we will move ahead and cover the
intermediate level JavaScript topics
like JavaScript functions strings and
arrays
following that we will cover important
topics like objects prototypal
inheritance and many more such topics
once we are done with the basic and
intermediate level topics we will move
on to some advanced level topics like
callback functions promises Arrow
functions regular expression and formal
Edition in JavaScript
will work on certain projects to end
this video we'll create a verbal game
and a functional website it is rightly
said that you can Master a programming
language just by programming in it I
hope you guys are ready to learn
something new so without any further Ado
let's start the first topic for the day
JavaScript was developed in the year
1995 by a person named Brendan Ike
Brendan was working for Netscape
Communications while he developed
JavaScript in 10 days
there were a few changes in the name of
JavaScript initially it was mocha which
was later changed to livescript and then
it finally became JavaScript the start
of JavaScript wasn't that good as so
many developers who were using Java at
that time
they considered JavaScript as a language
for designers and non-engineers no one
ever knew that this small side scripting
language would have a great future today
more than 90 of the websites out there
they are using JavaScript somehow many
of you guys gets confused with Java and
JavaScript let me clear it for you that
both Java and JavaScript they are
different languages they have almost
nothing in common many people say that
JavaScript was named after Java as a
part of a marketing strategy to gain
wider acceptance and recognition in 1995
Java was a buzzword when JavaScript was
developed that's why they renamed
JavaScript after Java let's move on to
what is Javascript
have you guys ever been through a
website where you can see images that
slides automatically one such website is
Amazon the home page of Amazon where we
can see different types of ongoing sales
is an example of JavaScript
in Layman language JavaScript is a
lightweight scripting language used to
make web pages more interactive and more
lively earlier when JavaScript was
developed it was only a side scripting
language to do basic tasks like you can
add pop-ups in your web page or you can
make your web page more interactive
nothing more than that but now the whole
scenario has changed with the help of
JavaScript we can create applications as
well
if we talk about applications let's take
an example let's suppose we want to
create an app we can create it in
Android or in iOS but we have to learn
few different languages to create those
apps for Android we have to learn Java
and XML and Swift We have to learn for
iOS but with the help of JavaScript you
can create hybrid applications which can
work on any platform without any problem
Tech giants like Google PayPal Amazon
and YouTube they are using JavaScript
these days the evolution of JavaScript
in the past few years was unbelievable
suppose you want to create a single page
website every one of us is familiar with
Gmail let's suppose so Gmail is a single
page website which looks more like
desktop software than a website so Gmail
is based on angular.js it is a popular
framework by Google which is free of
cost and it is totally based on
JavaScript now let's go over some of the
features of JavaScript these features
are actually why it is considered that
using JavaScript is advantages over
other languages
so let's start some of these points
JavaScript is not a proper programming
language indeed it is a scripting
language
which works in the runtime environment
just like python so there are few other
languages like C plus plus and Java they
need a compiler to work but with
JavaScript you don't need a compiler
once you are done with the script it
will interpret and show you the output
in the browser directly next up is
lightweighted Javascript can provide
programming facility to some extent in
JavaScript you don't need to specify any
data type or return type which helps in
making development more quicker that's
why it is known as light weighted
JavaScript is both client-side as well
as server side technology client-side
technology runs on the user's computer
whereas the server side technology runs
on the web browser initially when
JavaScript was introduced it was
introduced as a client-side technology
but with the introduction of node.js in
2009 one can now work in the back end as
well there is a way to validate the
user's Data before sending it to the web
server and we can do that with the help
of JavaScript the data will be checked
for correct form and value
all we have to do is start a loop give
it the condition
to check the data JavaScript is also
platform independent although originally
designed to work on browsers only but
now it is a platform independent
language which means once you are done
with the script you can use it on any
browser or platform without any problem
JavaScript is an object based scripting
language although many programmers do
not consider JavaScript as a true object
oriented programming language due to its
lack of class concept it does support
other features of object oriented
programming like it supports
encapsulation it supports polymorphism
and also it supports prototypal
inheritance the last but not the least
feature of JavaScript is case sensitive
so when it comes to keywords identifiers
names and functions JavaScript
differentiates between capital and
lowercase letters we have to keep this
in mind while programming
now I will quickly go over some of the
JavaScript applications where JavaScript
is currently being implemented first one
that comes to every person's mind is web
development it was also the main motive
behind developing JavaScript we have
Technologies like angular we have
node.js we can create beautiful web
pages also JavaScript can be used along
with HTML and CSS to make those static
looking web pages more engaging if we
talk about other applications of
JavaScript we can use it in app
development either mobile app or web app
like we took the example before that how
hybrid apps made with the help of
JavaScript can take over traditional
Android and iOS app one of the most
important and unique application of
JavaScript is in smart watches the
bangle.js is an open sourced Smartwatch
powered by JavaScript Gordon Williams
the man who is currently working on this
project it is said that this new open
sourced stack built around JavaScript
will replace the onboard firmware soon
the next application of JavaScript is
client-side validation as we discussed
earlier JavaScript is used to validate
the user data whether the user's input
is correct or Not by cross checking it
with the given condition like the user
wants to enter in your website and you
want it to be a user with at the rate
gmail.com in his email ID so you will
give that condition to JavaScript and it
will cross check it with the user's
information like when the user will try
to enter in your website it will check
that if at the rate gmail.com is there
or not in the user's email ID
so it can validate the user also apart
from that one more application of
JavaScript is game development
JavaScript can be used to make fully
fledged 2D or 3D games using different
libraries although most JavaScript game
development focuses on creating games
used in browsers only
till now we have an idea about what
JavaScript is its features and its
applications so if you want to learn
JavaScript you need to do some basic
things to make your learning experience
more smoother let's take a look at the
prerequisites to use JavaScript the
first one is the basic knowledge of HTML
and CSS to use JavaScript along with
HTML and CSS you first need to know how
HTML and CSS Works see HTML is used to
create the structure of a web page while
CSS is used to style that web page in
order to use these two with JavaScript
you need to have the basic knowledge of
HTML and CSS because if you want to
learn a new language first of all you
need to know why to use that technology
and to learn JavaScript more efficiently
you need to have the basic knowledge of
HTML and CSS it's better to have a web
browser that supports JavaScript like
Google Chrome or Mozilla Firefox or you
can use Safari as well if you are using
a MacBook you will need an operating
system like Windows Linux or Mac
operating system to learn JavaScript a
computer with minimum 512 MB of ram
would be enough for you to start
learning JavaScript but I will recommend
you a computer with 1GB of Ram or 4GB of
RAM for a better experience you can use
any text editor you have notepad which
is free and is already available for
Windows if you don't want to use notepad
you can use other free softwares like
sublime or you can use visual code in
this particular course we will be using
visual code and I'll tell you how to
install visual code and what are the
features of visual code also suppose you
do not have any prior knowledge about
JavaScript don't worry about it we will
take you through the whole course and we
will ensure that you can understand
JavaScript let's start this video with
some facts about JavaScript
JavaScript is the only programming
language that a browser can understand
25 years ago when developers were
thinking about a language that a browser
can understand
there were a few languages that were
present in the Market at that time just
like Java still there were some problems
with these languages that these
languages need a server to work with the
browser JavaScript on the other hand can
work directly with the browser you write
the code in the editor the browser will
go through it it will interpret it and
then runs the program
the popularity of JavaScript increased
with time
being a language which can do so many
tasks whether it be designing a
website's front end or going through any
website's backend JavaScript can do
anything by the end of 2018 over 95
percent of the internet was powered by
JavaScript means almost every website
out there is using JavaScript in some
way or another
do you guys know about stack Overflow a
website for every programmer don't worry
you will get to know about it once you
start with the programming part stack
Overflow states that JavaScript is the
most popular programming language used
by the developers let me quickly run you
through the reasons why one should learn
JavaScript and then we'll briefly
elaborate each of these reasons
JavaScript has the most powerful
Frameworks JavaScript is constantly
growing and is a well-paid job
JavaScript is beginner friendly and it
has the largest community
JavaScript provides wide range of usage
as well let's move on further and see
why each of these reason is important
JavaScript has the most powerful
Frameworks for every task user wants to
do like for designing a single page
website like you want to design a
website like Gmail you can use
angular.js if you want to design UI
components or user interfaces for single
page application you have react.js you
want to develop a mobile or a desktop
application let's suppose you have
view.js for that as well basically you
can do anything with powerful JavaScript
Frameworks next step is constant truth
one of the main reasons behind one
should learn JavaScript JavaScript is
one of the fastest growing languages and
stands among the top 10 languages used
by the developers with so much increase
in Mobile Market mobile web development
has seen an immense rise in need of
interactivity
which is Possible only with the help of
JavaScript that's why JavaScript is
continuously growing and there is no way
that JavaScript will go down shortly
the developers working in JavaScript are
well paid across the world anyone who
wants to be a web designer or a web
developer needs to learn JavaScript it
is a must have skill for being a good
web developer we will discuss it in
JavaScript jobs section
JavaScript is an easy to learn language
compared to many other programming
languages like Java Python and PHP
JavaScript provides easy entry points to
the world of programming the best thing
about JavaScript is that it comes
pre-installed on almost every web
browser so you don't need to set up any
environment to start development in
JavaScript which means you can start
coding right away
JavaScript has the largest community
among all the programming languages out
there
Community size does matter when it comes
to programming language because the
larger the community size is the more
help you would be likely to get
currently JavaScript has the biggest
stack Overflow Community it has
overtaken Java in terms of community
size and is still growing at a rapid
Pace wide range of usage in my opinion
one of the most important reasons why
one should learn JavaScript by knowing
JavaScript you can build an entire
website from its backend to the front
apart from that you can also build a
full flash mobile application for the
back end you don't need to learn other
programming languages node.js is enough
with a bit of knowledge about database
and apis this is nothing you can't do
with JavaScript when it comes to website
development
let's move on and discuss few jobs you
can take up after learning JavaScript
and we'll also discuss their average
salaries in USA and in India
so the first one is a full stack
developer a full stack developer is one
of the highest paid jobs in web
development sector a full stack
developer is equally proficient in
client-side as well as server side
development a full stack developer earns
around 9 lakh per annum which is quite a
decent amount of money for a person
living in India but if you are a full
stack developer in US you can earn up to
hundred thousand dollars per annum which
is a huge amount
front-end developer is the one who deals
with the front end of any website or
application it's obvious that a
front-end developer will not earn as
much as a full stack developer but the
amount of money a front-end developer
earns in a year is decent a JavaScript
developer works on the front end and
sometimes backend also
a JavaScript developer may be
responsible for the whole website or
just a few aspects or pages of different
websites they earn quite well when it
comes to salary a JS developer in US
earns around 75 000 per annum which when
converted to Indian rupees sums around
55 lakhs approx which is a huge amount
designing a UI is an interesting job as
it needs creativity along with skills
it's always fun to design interfaces to
attract users one should need a lot of
creativity for this job the amount of
money a UI ux designer earns in India is
around 7 lakh per annum but it can go up
as much as 20 lakh per annum depends
upon the skills possessed and creativity
of the designer so choose your career
wisely let's start this video with the
introduction to Dom
Dom stands for document object model it
is an API for HTML and XML documents
which helps JavaScript to understand
what is their return inside the HTML
document API stands for application
programming interface to understand API
better let's take an example of a
restaurant
imagine yourself in the restaurant you
are sitting at the table with the menu
the chef in the kitchen is also part of
the system the waiter here works as a
messenger between you and the chef
that's what API does it works as a
moderator between JavaScript and the
HTML document Dom defines the whole HTML
document in a hierarchical form to make
it understandable for JavaScript so that
other JavaScript functions can work over
it it represents the entire document in
the form of object and nodes whether it
be elements or text or anything stored
in the document the entire page content
can be accessed or manipulated by
JavaScript
Dom is not used with JavaScript only
other languages like python also uses
dom dom was designed to be used
independently to begin with dom there is
nothing special you have to do different
browsers have different implementation
of the document object model every
browser uses Dom to make the web page of
the document accessible by JavaScript
let's move on and see what is document
object model with the help of an example
I believe you guys have the basic
knowledge of HTML and CSS a prerequisite
for this course let's start things off
with a basic HTML example here we have a
code that consists tags like HTML head
body heading tag Etc we have the HTML
tag here the opening HTML tag and the
closing HTML tag inside the HTML tag we
have the head tag which contains the
documents header part inside the head
tag there is a title tag that contains
the title of the web page then comes the
body tag which contains a heading tag
and two div tags with IDs as div 1 and
div2 a div tag defines a particular
section in the HTML document the ID used
within the div tag it is an attribute
basically that has to be unique within
the document to make the element unique
from other elements next up we have a
paragraph tag with a class attribute
within it CSS and JavaScript uses
classes to select and access specific
elements don't worry guys if you have no
idea about it let us first see the
output of this code before going to the
document object model of this whole
document so guys this is the output of
the previous code we just came through
here we can see the title of the web
page as well as heading after it there
were two different div tags used in the
code here is the output of both the div
tags the question here is where are
those ID and class attributes seen in
the out output the answer to this
question is there's nothing on this web
page that can show both of them we can
use them in our CSS file or through
JavaScript to specify the containers in
which they are used so we have concluded
how a normal document works and how the
browser interprets the HTML cool but how
JavaScript uses this code is a bit
different that's where Dom comes into
play when the actual HTML document is
loaded in the browser another
representation of that document is
created known as document object model
here's the model you can see on your
screen
each of the tags used in HTML document
is correspondingly represented as object
in the doll like starting from the HTML
tag and covering all the other tags like
head title body and few more the same
hierarchy as there was in the HTML
document goes with the document object
model also document to object model is
simply the same HTML document with
different representation the reason
behind this different representation is
that it's easy for JavaScript to
interpret this format JavaScript can't
understand tags but it can understand
these objects JavaScript can easily
manipulate these objects using different
functions which we will see in future
while working on these function for
example if you want to access the text
present inside the heading tag you can
do it by accessing The Heading tag with
JavaScript you can also work on the
style of this text with the help of
JavaScript as well JavaScript uses the
concept of nodes it can access nodes of
the document object model there are many
types of nodes present in the Dom the
basic three types are element node
attribute node and text node the element
node consists of all the tags used in
HTML document like the head tag and the
body tag the attribute node contains the
attributes used in HTML document by now
I hope you have understood the concept
of attributes so JavaScript can access
these attributes as well and the user
can work upon them as per requirements
the text here in the HTML document that
is simply
it can also be accessed with the help of
JavaScript it is the value of that
particular element before installing vs
code let's discuss a few things about
what is an IDE
so IDE stands for integrated development
environment it is a software application
basically it comprehends facilities to a
programmer for software development just
like photoshops makes it easier for us
to edit photos in the same way IDE makes
it easier for a programmer to write code
if you want to write code IDE will help
you write that and it will help you in
software development
there are a number of Ides present in
the market today we have Sublime we have
pycharm we have comodo we have notepad
and notepad plus plus as well but in
this particular course we will be using
visual studio code or vs code we can say
so let me run you through some of the
advantages that why we are using vs code
for this course so first of all vs code
is free to use as it is a open source
software so you can use it without any
cost
it supports multiple programming
languages there is nothing like you need
any web support or work on different
editors for different programming you
can use vs code for different languages
extensions are also one of the main
reasons behind using vs code see you
want to work on a programming language
it does not support all you have to do
is add an extension search for it and
you are good to go it will also not
affect the speed of the editor as it
runs as a different process it can also
detect code snippet whether it is
complete or not like you are using a
variable in your program and you forgot
to declare it vs code will do it for you
this property is known as intellisense
besides all these properties one main
key feature behind using vs code is it
is cross platform it is available for
Mac it is available for Linux and
windows as well I think there are enough
features we have discussed till now
there are many more features we will
discuss them while installing or while
working in vs code so for now let's move
on to the installation process the
installation process for vs code is
pretty simple just go to Google and
search for vs code
the next page which will open here you
can see that the first link available is
from their official website click on
that and you will go to their official
website here in the front you can see
the download this you can download the
stable version from here only or if you
want to download it for you according to
your PC's specifications you can click
on the download button present at the
top right corner of your screen here you
can see that vs code is available for
different platforms it is available for
Windows for Linux and for Mac as well
you can download it from here as well so
if you want to download this for Windows
you can click here
it will take you to another page and it
will start downloading vs once the
download completes open the setup file
from your downloads and it will take you
to the license agreement page you have
to agree with all the terms and
condition you can go through the full
license but then it will take a lot of
time to go through all this once you
click on it this window will open where
you have to select the location you want
your vs code to locate
any ID you install the default location
for all the editors is the same you can
click on browse and select any other
location if you want but for now I'll be
leaving it as it is and I'll click on
next now this will open and you will
click next from here now it will ask you
some questions like if you want to
create a desktop icon or not select all
of them and click on next now click on
install and it will install vs code for
you sit back and relax it will take time
so once you are done with the
installation process click on finish and
the visual studio code will start
automatically
so here we are you can see that we are
on the welcome page so let's start with
these icon present on the left side of
the editor this icon here is exploded so
vs code works with the folders in your
system click on open folder
and just search any folder or you can
take any folder of your choice so here
in my PC I'll go to work and I'll
take JavaScript as my folder I'll select
it and see it will open the folder and I
already have a few programs written over
here like this
and I have a few more programs like this
and this you can open any program from
that folder by using this Explorer
option you can open any program present
in that folder so basically what it does
any program you make in Visual Studio
code you will save it in this folder
only so it will be easy for you to open
any program anytime next up we have the
search button to find any keyword or
word present in your code whatever you
write here it will show you where it is
present in your code or in your document
so let's suppose I write here simply
learn C it will show you simply learn in
your main screen so you have a shortcut
key for this also press Ctrl F from your
keyboard and write anything here like
it's written simply linear press enter
and it will show you the result the
third option here is for Version Control
if you want to use any Version Control
like you want to use git vs code has
very good integration with Git the next
button here is for debug or it will run
your program once you are done with
writing the code click here and run and
debug just open it with chrome you have
a shortcut for this as well press F5
from your keyboard and it will do the
same the next button here is for
extensions here you can find many
extensions given by the vs code
Community they are free to use for now
we will use these three extensions the
first one is HTML CSS support just click
on the search button write HTML CSS
support the first option click on that
and install that extension similarly you
have to install few modes you have to
install JavaScript and type script
nightly
and you have to install live server in
the same way I'll tell you the use of
live server in the next video when we
will be writing our first hello world
program let me end this video by giving
you a shortcut let's create a new file
here click here create a new file
is
close it create a new file we will name
it as new DOT HTML so it's new DOT HTML
here one thing you have to keep in mind
while saving a file make sure to save
that file with DOT HTML extension here
we are about to start writing our first
program so just write
exclamation mark and press enter
it will do this see it will write the
basic HTML code which you will need in
almost every program from now on so you
don't have to write this code every time
just do it this way and start writing
main program we are using vs code Studio
as a text editor to write the script
here we have already discussed the
benefits as well as the features of vs
code in the previous video so as I have
already mentioned you must have a web
browser with JavaScript enabled in it so
if you are using Google Chrome it's
quite easy to enable JavaScript let me
take you through open Google Chrome go
to settings and just write JavaScript in
the search option go to site settings
and scroll down you will find here
JavaScript allow it if it's not allowed
in my case it's already allowed so I'm
good to go once you have downloaded the
editor and you are done with the
environment setup and all you can start
writing the program so let's go to es
code we will open a new file here and
save it with the name let's open a new
file and we will save it with name
first dot HTML make sure to save your
file with DOT HTML extension as it will
make it easy for the computer to
understand that this particular file is
an HTML file so in the last video we
installed an extension named live server
let me tell you how to use it and what
are the benefits of using live server so
let's write a basic HTML program or just
press the exclamation key and press
enter here we are with the basic HTML
program we have not done anything yet
just edit it a little bit we'll add a
heading tag and inside the heading tag
we will write a heading let's suppose we
are writing
hello so now right click on your desktop
and click on open with live server
but this will do it will open your
program in the browser see it's the
basic thing so let me tell you what its
benefits are it will open your program
in the browser and whatever changes you
are making in the programs will be
directly shown in the browser the moment
you save them see just use Google Chrome
or whatever browser you are using and in
the vs code side by side we'll be using
it side by side now let's suppose we'll
change something here let's add a word
here hello
world and the moment we save it it will
be reflected in your browser as well so
that's the benefit of using live server
we'll be using it during our whole code
so now we are done with that let's start
with the program so here we are with a
basic HTML code which has only tags in
it it will print that thing if I remove
this heading tag let me remove and
moment I save it it will print nothing
so guys let me give you a brief
introduction to these tags these HTML
tags are used to render HTML files
properties so that the browser can
differentiate between simple text and
HTML tags you can use as many tags
according to your requirements in our
first program we will write a single
line statement over the browser for that
we will need the script tag don't worry
if you don't know much about script Tech
let me tell you briefly about this text
functionality it is used to embed a
client-side script language remember
guys script tag is used to embed
JavaScript with HTML this is where HTML
and JavaScript comes together
it may contain the scripting statements
or Point towards the external script
through the SRC attribute we will see
the SRC attribute as well we'll use the
script tag inside the body tag or we can
use it wherever we want to use it like
it's not necessary to use it inside the
body tag only we can use it anywhere in
a program so let's start with this
first
let's start the scripted
and we are done with it now the script
tag we have to type an attribute
the attribute is the type is it's a text
file
we are done with our script tag to write
on the web page we use a very basic
command the document.write
it is a JavaScript method using which
you can print anything on the browser
let's see what document.write can do
let's write here something
document dot right
and any text you want to write inside it
let's suppose hello world
welcome to
simply code
so guys we are done with this we have
written a text over here hello world
welcome to Simply code let's see what
will happen when we save it
press Ctrl s and the moment you save it
here it will be reflected on your
browser here you can see in our browser
it's written over here hello world
welcome to Simply code we can Define
JavaScript in an external file as well
let's see how we can do this how this
script tag will Point towards an
external Javascript file here what you
have to do you have written script just
before type use an attribute SRC and
give it the source of the file but till
now we don't have any Javascript file so
let's create a file burst name it as
script.js remember you have to save it
with DOT JS extension we are done with
it and we are good to go so here we will
write document
dot right
and any text you want to write here
hello world welcome to
simply learn we will save it the moment
we will save it here
there's something wrong I guess
okay we have not given the source code
of that JavaScript so here we have to
give the name of that file it was
script.js
moment we will save it see the text is
changed here initially it was Hello
World welcome to Simply code but now it
is Hello World welcome to Simply learn
this document.write is not interpreted
by the browser that's because this
script tag is now pointing towards an
external Javascript file anything you
will write inside this script tag will
not be considered now so we are done
with this script tag here we now have an
idea of how to embed JavaScript with
HTML and now let's see some of the
features of document.right so let's
suppose you are you have written this
text here let's erase it and see what
else it can do let's give it a task to
add two numbers let's suppose we have
given you nine plus three let's see if
it works see it will give you the output
directly here document dot right nine
plus three it will give you the output
as 12. similarly you will do any
mathematical task any calculation you
want to do
let's suppose
7 multiply by
8.
see you can see here 12 56 Square let's
give it another one 9 multiply 5 minus
let's suppose 3 and save it 3 9 into 5
is 45 and if you minus 3 from 45 you'll
get 42 here is the answer for s42 56 is
for 7 into 8 7 multiplied by 8 and 12 is
for 9 plus 3. so with that we are done
with how to embed with a JavaScript with
HTML let's move on to another Concept in
JavaScript that is console.log console
log is a function in JavaScript that
works the same as document.write but it
will not print anything in the browser
let's give it a try let's
clear this and suppose we write here
console Dot Lock
and give it a command
save it and see there is nothing printed
on the browser let's write something in
the body tag we'll use a heading tag and
write something here let's go again and
go to body type we'll use a heading tag
here as well
and write something here let's suppose
we write simply code save it see this is
printed on the browser to open your
browsers console go to browser right
click here and go to inspect element or
you can use Control Plus shift plus I
which I normally do here you can see the
console option see it has many options
like elements consoles courses Network
and many more but for now let's focus on
Console here you can see the text
printed here so what's the point of
doing this whenever we write a code we
usually have many variables and
functions and a lot of these kinds of
things we don't always know what to
expect as the output maybe we expect a
particular result but we might get
something else one way of debugging our
code is that we can pass a value to this
function here only and we can check the
result of that value out of the code
let's add two numbers here so if you
don't understand it basically what we
are doing for now we are writing a small
piece of code like the program is not
that big but later on when we are good
with JavaScript and we will use
JavaScript as a primary language the
size of the program will go longer and
longer so not every time you are
supposed to check the output of your
code by doing that only so if you are
using any variables or you are using any
functions you can check the output here
only if you have to use that variable in
that way or you have to change something
so you will get it here only that's the
use of console.log let's add two numbers
and remove it a is equal to 5 and let
these value is 8 suppose
okay we are done with these two numbers
and we will what we'll do we will write
console.log
we have given it the command to add a
and b let's see if it works here
see the value of a plus b is 13. you can
see it here in console the value is 13
you can see it here so here we can see
that the output is 13 you can do any
complex calculation here in the console
it will give you the correct answer you
can see here script.js column four the
number after the column is the line in
script dot JS here in our file we can
see that the console.log command is in
line number four so here it is written
that it is line number four here so if
you click on this
you can see the script.js opened in a
very small window and you can edit it
from here as well so this is not a
random line number to prove this let's
go on to our program and let's move this
to another line see now the console.log
is in line 11. save it and here you can
see this also changed to 11 so let's
make this more complex add another
variable C we'll add another variable
here let suppose we had C here we'll
give it a more complex equation let's
suppose let C equals to
the moment we save it it will give it
the answer oh no we are done with the
equation let's change it here also the
value of
C is
let's see if it works or not press Ctrl
s it's saved and the value of C is seven
let's see if this value is correct or
not the value of a was 5 5 into 3 is 15
15 plus 8 is 23 23 plus 4 is 27. 27 plus
a minus 25 value of a is 5 minus 25 is
minus 20 27 minus 20. the value of C is
7 say it's correct
check it yourself if you can do
something more interesting with this
control DOT log or you can do something
more interesting with document dot right
so console log allows us to debug our
code and we can use it if we are not
sure about the output in a lengthy
program in the previous video we learned
about a first JavaScript program I
explained you some basic things like if
you want to perform addition if you want
to add two numbers or you want to
perform subtractions and multiplication
and division as well before moving
forward to statements and comments here
to take a note
while you are performing any calculation
let me show you see if you are
performing any calculation let's copy it
from here and paste it here
so yeah if you want to perform and let's
add two numbers like we want to add 45
and
we'll add let's say 5. we'll save it and
here you can see the answer is 50 here
right so if you want to perform any
calculation you have to write as it is
you can't write any calculation within
inverted comma or double inverted comma
let's try this if you want to write any
calculation within a single inverted
comma the moment you save it it will
print it as 45 plus 5. what the browser
will do the browser will interpret it as
text and print it as it is so there will
be no change so keep that in mind take a
note of it and we are done with it right
now so let's move on to statements in
JavaScript so guys whenever you use any
programming language you give the
computer
some instruction to perform any task or
activity that's common in all
programming languages present out there
like you are giving computers a few
instructions to do a particular task
these instruction you are giving to the
computer are known as statements you see
the code written over here this
document.write function is an
instructional statement given to the
computer to write something on the
browser like if you are writing hello
world inside this function it will print
it in the browser as it is and same for
addition subtraction multiplication and
whatever you are writing inside it it
will basically print it on browser like
let's suppose if we write here something
else
let's suppose we write here inside
double
inverted comma
welcome to Simply code we save it we are
basically giving it the instruction to
write this on the browser so what it
will do it will write it as it is on the
browser these are the instructions we
are giving to a machine to perform a
basic task or to perform a certain task
so if you are writing a whole program
for designing a website or for anything
you must be using more than one
statement you will use a lot of
statements in a single program
so all these statements are separated by
semicolons like here you can see after
every statement I have written a
semicolon it's necessary let me show you
an example see we'll remove this
statement and we'll copy this line and
paste it in the next line and write
something else here what we can say this
is our first program we will write like
suppose I have written it I'll give it
the semicolon here the moment I'll save
it see you can see here it's written
that hello world the first statement
statement is interpreted and written
over here then second it come to welcome
to Simply code see here you can see that
I have not written any semicolon but
it's still showing the output
so let me tell you something interesting
so if you remove the semicolon from any
of these statement here it will work
fine which means JavaScript will forgive
you for these small errors you do but
it's always a good practice to put a
semicolon after every statement because
while writing a whole program in future
you will use n number of statements and
let's see what happen if you try to
write more than one statement in a
single line without any semicolon let's
do this thing here write more than one
statement in a single line and I'll save
it see it won't work the moment I put a
semicolon here and save it it will work
fine
so that's why I am saying that it is a
good practice to use semicolon after
each statement
hope you guys are getting this let's
move on to comments so a comment is also
common for almost all programming
languages it's a line in programming
language which do not have any effect on
the output of the program see it stays
there in the code but it does not affect
the output by any means a comment may be
a multi-line comment or a single line
comment as well to write a single line
comment we just use double slash in
front of that statement like here if we
see the output is Hello World welcome to
Simply code this is our first program so
to make this first statement a comment
what we'll do we'll use two forward
slashes in front of it and it will
become a comment so the moment we will
save it this hello world is disappeared
from the output
so this is how to use a single line
comment a comment won't affect your
program by any means let's move on to
multi-line comments to write a
multi-line comment you have to use
forward slash along with the asterisk
sign see if you want to make these two
line cells comments to end a comment we
will use asterisk sign with a forward
slash these two statements are comments
now so the moment you will save it
welcome to Simply code is also
disappeared from the output that's how
comment work they won't affect your
programs output but comments are very
useful in programming it's just a note
for the programmers to remember what
they did at that particular part of the
program suppose you write a program see
here the programs are not that large and
the coding is not that much but in
future when you write a program maybe
the program will be of more than 500
lines or more so suppose you write a
program with more than 500 lines and
come back 20 days later so at that time
you can't go through the whole code this
is where comments will help you in
JavaScript it will help you to remember
what you did at that particular part of
the program so variables are named
storage that a program can manipulate as
the name suggests a variable is a value
that can change according to conditions
variables refers to those memory blocks
inside the computer where we can store
information let's suppose you want to
store any value inside your computer so
variable will represent the location of
that value
in simple terms variables are cups with
stuff inside them and you can use that
stuff later again and again according to
the way you want to before the
introduction of es6 or ecmascript we can
say which is the updated version of
JavaScript variables were declared using
a single keyword only which is where
we'll try to declare a few variables
here we'll see how where keyword works
so let's comment this thing first
so let's declare a few variables let's
suppose where a equals to 15 will
declare
where B and the value of B will be 6 we
will declare where
C and the value of C would be a plus b
so here we have defined three variables
a b and c a is a variable with value 15
stored inside it and so is B the value
of B is 6 but C is a variable that will
contain the value of a plus b let's try
to print this on browser
document dot right
and we will print the value of C
save it and here you can see the value
of C is 21.
that's the correct answer so similarly
you can also print a and b as well let's
print a and b as well here
what we will do we'll copy this line
we'll paste it for a n
will update this here as well
so it won't create any confusion
so here you can see the value of C is 21
the value of a is 15 and the value of B
is 6. it shows the value of all the
three variables we declared but with the
introduction of es6 or ecmascript in
2015 two more ways were introduced to
declare a variable these are let end
const we shall discuss these two terms
in the later part of this session let me
show you how to declare a variable there
are a few things you have to keep in
mind while declaring a variable name
here we have seen we use three variables
a b and c that was an easy task to do
but giving a variable any name like
something other than a single alphabet
so you have to keep a few things in mind
while naming them start them with the
letter underscore or a dollar sign you
can't use any sign except underscore or
dollar so if you are giving a variable
name you can't use any other sign except
the underscore or the dollar sign you
can use these two signs only you can't
use any other sign
you can't use a number in the starting
apart from that let's suppose you want
to give it a name as 9be you can't do
that in JavaScript JavaScript won't
allow you this if you try to save it it
will throw you an error invalid or
unexpected token so you can't do this in
JavaScript there is no limit for the
length of the variable name but you
can't use reserved keywords in a
variable name like let's try to create a
variable with name as class class is a
reserved keyword in JavaScript we'll
save it and see here throws an error
unexpected token class but you can use a
class with capital c let's save it and
here it will work fine
why it works because JavaScript
variables are case sensitive if we try
to create a variable with same name
Let's see we try to create a variable
with where girl and the another variable
will be where girl with capital G this
time JavaScript will treat these two
variables differently these two are
different variables for JavaScript as
JavaScript is case sensitive when it
comes to variables
let's declare a few more variables let's
remove it we'll declare a few more
variable let's comment this part as well
it will declare a few more variables
suppose we declare a variable with
keyword where and we'll name this
variable as bikening where byte name
and press enter
if we leave this variable without
assigning it any value the by default
value will be undefined let's try to
print the value of this variable
right we will try to print the value of
byte name
save it here you can see the value it
shows is undefined so the by default
value of a variable if you do not assign
it any value will be undefined let's try
to give it a value let's suppose we
try to give bike name
we use equals to operator to assign it a
value cosine let's suppose we'll assign
it Yamaha
semicolon and press Ctrl s to save this
and here you can see the output as
Yamaha you can also assign a value to
the variable during declaration as we
have done in the previous examples here
we have assigned the variables value at
the time of Declaration only let's move
on to let and const so we will discuss
let and Cones but first we will compare
let with where let is also used to
declare a variable just like where is
used but there is a limitation to use
let
is not accessible outside the Block in
which it is declared
so we will use let here only let by name
equals and we will change this value as
well we'll change it to Hero let's say
save it and here you can see the output
as hero but if we try to put this code
inside a block let's suppose we put this
code inside this block a pair of curly
braces and we will again try to access
document dot right we will try to access
bike name again from here from outside
the block we try to access this save it
and here you can see bike name is not
defined it is an error in line 18. so
what's happening here basically you
can't access a let variable outside the
scope you can't access it from here but
it will work with where we try to
replace let with where and save it here
you can see it says hero and hero
because first it will interpret this
method and then it will interpret this
as well in case of where due to its
limited scope light variables are used
when there is limited use only like in
for Loop or in while loop we will learn
these Loop in future let will not allow
you to redeclare any variable let's
understand this with an example here's
the code as well we have declared where
bike name and we'll remove this and
first we will try to do this with where
let's suppose where bike name
equals to TVs Control Plus s it says
hero and TVs so the variable name the
bike name is same in both cases here and
here as well these are same but with
where keyword you can do that let will
not allow you to do this if we use let
here in place of where we'll write let
as here as well and we will change the
value as well we will give it as
Kawasaki
and
let's suppose Suzuki here
save it
see bike name has already been declared
so that's what let won't allow you to do
you can repeat the same light variable
in different scope it won't create any
problem but it will not allow you to
redeclare any declared variable so let's
move on to const we use const when there
are values we don't want to change or
that will never change basically so the
keyword cost is little misleading as it
defines a constant reference to a value
not the constant value we can't change
the Primitive value but we can change
the properties of constant objects let's
write another piece of code for const
keyword
so let's declare a variable const
X is equal to
5.
comma Y is equal to
7 let's say fonts
so here what we have done we declared a
variable X and a variable y with value
as 5 and 7 we declared this time with
const keyword and the variable Z which
is X Plus y we printed Z on the browser
and it shows the value as 12 which is X
Plus y 7 plus 5 is equal to 12. now what
we will do const will let you do this
but if you try to update the value of x
let's suppose we try to update the value
of x as x equals to X
Plus 10.
we'll print X this time
document dot right
X let's save this it will throw an error
assignment to a constant variable in
line 24 so here you want to update the
value of x you can't do this with const
keyword you can do this with let and
where as well but you can't do this with
const also const won't allow you to
re-declare any variable just like let so
if you try to use const x again
is equal to 10 save it
so here it says identifier X has already
been declared this thing you can do with
cons the scope of const is the same as
lead it can be used within the block
where it is declared data types is an
essential Concept in every programming
language to work on any variable you
should know its type
it refers to the kind of data which is
being stored inside a variable the type
of variable is holding basically
every programming language has its own
set of data types which is unique in its
own way
we discussed earlier that JavaScript is
a lightweight scripting language because
we don't need to specify any data type
in JavaScript after all all the
variables in JavaScript are Loosely
packed or we can say JavaScript is a
dynamically typed scripting language we
shall discuss these properties later in
this video for now let me tell you about
different data types present in
JavaScript
so JavaScript data types are divided
into two categories primitive data types
and non-primitive data types primitive
data types are stored in stack whereas
non-premitive data types they are stored
in Heap I don't want you to go deep in
these two terms as if you are new to
programming so we'll leave it just keep
one thing in mind that primitive data
types are base data types whereas
non-primitive data types are objects or
we can say they are derived
primitive data types they are further
divided into five categories they are
divided as numbers strings Boolean
undefined and null non-primitive data
types or complex data types we can say
on the other hand they are divided into
two parts arrays and objects will have
separate videos on these topics for now
let's discuss primitive data types to
understand primitive data types much
better let's declare a few variable here
let's say we declare where X and give it
the value as 16. will declare where Y
and will give it value
hello world we'll declare one more let's
say where
flag
and the value will be true
here we can talk about those properties
of JavaScript which I mentioned earlier
JavaScript variables are Loosely packed
and JavaScript is dynamically typed
scripting language these two points
refer to the same thing here you can see
we have defined three variables X we
have defined variable X we have defined
variable Y and flag as well the values
for all three variables is different
from one another
see variable X is holding a value that
is 16 variable Y is holding a value
hello world which is a string so 16 is a
number hello world is a string and
variable flag is holding a value that
refers to a Boolean value in place of
true we can also write false here
so what's happening here here you can
see there is no data type if you are
coming from a C plus plus background or
a Java background this will be a little
bit weird for you guys because in C plus
plus and Java we used to do it like we
will define an integer let let me show
you
so how we will Define integer in C plus
plus or Java what we'll say we'll use
intx equals to 5
or something like that we already had a
data type for string as well we have
carrying C plus plus but here in
JavaScript we have no data type we are
only using the where keyword that's what
we call as Loosely typed
this line means that you don't have to
define the data type of the variable
what happens in JavaScript is whatever
the type of value you will pass to the
variable the data type will change
accordingly
so you don't need to worry about if you
are passing a number or if you are
passing in string
just relax just when you pass the value
to the variable it will be determined
automatically so these are the three
basic primitive data types present in
JavaScript which are number
Boolean value and string
so let's move on to the next one which
is undefined it will Define a variable p
and we'll leave it as it is so this
variable P has an undefined data type it
means that any variable which is already
declared but has no value inside it it
has an undefined data type
I'll tell you a basic operator the type
of operator
we'll go through the operators in later
videos but just try to understand the
basic need and use it with me for now
this operator will help you know the
type of value a variable is holding see
let's use it here we have declared a
variable P we'll check the type of P so
to use this operator you have to use it
with document dot right now
so we will do document.write and we'll
use two brackets
and inside it will write
type of and whatever like we want to
know the type of variable X let's
suppose we'll write here x
semicolon save it and you can see here
it says number this means that this
variable has a value which is a number
similarly we will check for all the
variables present here we'll check for
every variable we'll check for y will
check for flag and we'll check for p as
well let's copy this and
paste it three times and let's change
the value here from X to Y in this line
and from X to flag here
and here we'll change it to p
so we have done it we'll save it and see
here it says number first variable y it
says it's a string because you know
hello world is a string it's a sequence
of character for variable flag it says
Boolean so it's defined as true or false
and for variable P it's written here
undefined with this we are left with
only one primitive data type the null
data type there's a difference between a
null value and an undefined value
undefined means lack of value whereas
null means the absence of any value
suppose you are using null as the value
for any variable the type of operator
will return this variable as an object
but if you are not giving any value to
this variable you are leaving it after
declaration the type of operator will
return undefined here's an example for
this C will declare one more variable
here we'll declare where num let's name
this variable num and we will give it
the value as null we will use
document.write type of and we will check
with the help of type of operator that
what type of value the variable num is
holding so let's give here
num
we are good to go press Ctrl s and C
here it says it's an object
so a null value will always be shown as
an object we'll talk about the complex
types or composite types in further
videos we'll have separate videos for
each of these types type conversion as
the name suggests conversion of value
from one to another in the previous
video we declared a few variables we
declared numbers strings and Boolean as
well in JavaScript you can change the
data type of any variable from one to
another you can change a number to a
string or a string to a number let's see
an example of type conversion let's
declare a variable here
let's suppose we are using a variable
let's say where num equals to and the
value will be 34 and will print it first
and we'll use type of operator to see
the data type of this variable
save it and see here it shows 34 and a
number I have already told you about the
use of console.log in this topic we'll
use console.log just for a change you
can use document.write as well there is
no problem with any method you are using
let's move ahead and we'll declare a few
more variables we'll declare a string
and a Boolean as well
let's suppose where Str equals to
hello
and we'll print it as well let's copy it
from here and paste it here
and we'll declare one more variable
let's say where Bool equals to
true
let's print these three variables first
see the output is pretty simple we can
see the value and data types as well see
34 is a number hello is a string and
true is a Boolean value
so let's convert this number to a string
first this number 34 this is a number
here right and we'll convert this number
to a string so how to do it that's
pretty simple all you have to do is
write a word here let's write here write
string with a capital s
and put 34 inside a bracket so here we
are done with it save it and see here
you can see 34 which was a number first
and now it's changed to a string
that's how you can change the data type
of any variable let's try to change a
Boolean value to a string now many of
you guys gets confused with Boolean so
Boolean is nothing
if something is true then set it to true
and if something is not true like if
it's false then set it to false see if
we talk about a real life example say if
you know how to drive create a variable
drive and set it to true and if you
don't know how to write set the variable
to false that's pretty simple that's
what Boolean is let's change a Boolean
variable to a string we have to follow
the same steps as we did for numbers
what we did we'll write here string and
put true inside brackets
foreign
we are done with it save it and check
the output here you can see the type
change from Boolean to string like
string function we can also change a
string value to a number
so how to do it let's take a variable
let's say where str1 will take let's say
we are giving it a numeric value let's
say eight nine six eight
and what we'll do we'll write here
console log and will print it basically
str1 and we'll write here as well
save it and here you can see 8968 is a
string so how to change this string to a
number that's also a simple task all you
have to do is write here number with
capital n and put this value inside
brackets
save it and see here you can see 8968
changed to a number it was a string
earlier and now it's a number so if it's
a number now let's update this number
and we will see if we are adding
something to 8968 the value will change
or not let's update str1 what we'll do
we'll write str1 equals to str1
plus let's add a number say
so the output should be eight nine seven
zero and the type of operator will give
the value as number let's see what's the
output now save it and see here you can
see the output changed to 8970 but if
you add an alphabet or a character in
the value then the output will be
different here we will copy this whole
code
and we'll paste it here
we'll change the value of str1 equals to
str2 and we'll use an alphabet along
with this number let's suppose it's 8968
a so a is in alphabet and what we'll do
we'll comment this line and we'll go
here and change the value str1
here we are done with it save it here
you can see it says n a n it means that
it's not a number it won't treat this
string as a number because it consists
of both numeric value as well as
character
now let's try to convert a Boolean value
to a number in the case of a Boolean
variable the scenario is a bit different
let's try this
let's declare a variable let's say we
are using where Bool 2
and the value will be true
what we'll do we'll print the value here
you can see true and the data type of
true is Boolean so let's try to change
this Boolean value to a number that's
pretty simple task write a number and
put true inside brackets
save it and here you can see it says one
in case of Boolean variable the value of
true is 1 and the value of false is 0.
remember this guys keep this thing in
mind if you are changing a Boolean
variable to a number then the value of
true will be changed to 1 and the value
of false will be changed to 0.
now let's have a look at percent and
parse float as well after which I'll
tell you one more interesting function
let's move on to percent first here I'll
declare a variable let's suppose I am
declaring a variable let's say where and
we'll name this variable as number
the value will be a string let's suppose
it's 56
we will print it console.log
here you can see that the output is
showing 56 is a string so the data type
here is string because I have used here
single inverted comma so it will take 56
as a string
now
let's suppose I want to parse this as an
integer or say I want to change it to a
number I can use percent as well apart
from number if you want to use number
that's fine but apart from number if you
want to use percent you can use it
let's see what happens if you use
parsint use percent and put 56 inside a
bracket
save it and see here it changed the
string to a number 56 was a string
earlier right and now it's a number just
like percent we have parse float as well
parse float will do the same thing but
what if you are using a decimal number
here let's see if you are using 56.343
save it
but percent will do it will give you
let's change 56 first let's suppose we
are using 65 now save it and see percent
will give you the value as 65 only it
won't show you the value the decimal
value
but if you are using here number or pass
float it will give you the whole numeric
value let's see what happens if you use
number here
number and save it here you can see the
value is
65.343 like number if you are using here
pass float
let's use parse float you
and we'll change the value here as well
let's suppose it's 72 point
543 save it and see here it will give
you the whole numeric value of the
variable I hope this is clear for you
guys
now there is one more function you can
use in numbers which is dot 2 fixed so
this function has by default zero value
let's suppose I am using here we have to
use it here only let's see what happens
if I'm using number Dot
to fixed
so inside bracket we are giving it a
value by default the value is 0 Let's
suppose we are giving it the value as 2.
now save it and what will happen it will
give you the value as 72.54 similarly if
you are using here some other number
let's suppose seven you can see we have
only three digits here after the decimal
we have three digits only that is five
four and three what happens if we run
this program now let's save it and see
it says five four three zero zero zero
zero so it will show you the value up to
seven decimal points it doesn't matter
if there are available numbers after
decimal point but it will show you the
value instead of 7 you can also give
here 30 let's save it and see it says
6366 and so on hope this is clear for
you guys in any programming language an
operator is a symbol that makes the
computer understand that it needs to do
some specific tasks like if you want to
perform an addition between two numbers
let's say we want to perform addition
between four and five so guys if you see
the plus sign here this is known as the
operator and the two terms which are
four and five these two numbers these
are known as the operands
we have different operators for
different purposes like we have Plus for
addition we have minus for subtraction
we have star or asterisk we can say for
multiplication and many more other
operators as well so there are many more
operators present in almost every
programming language which is present
out there like it operators are present
in Java they are present in C plus plus
in C almost every programming language
out there has the concept of operators
it's essential for you to know how and
where to use any operator despite of the
language you are working on one needs to
understand which operators are available
right so in this particular video I'll
take you through the basic types of
operator present in JavaScript I'll let
you know the types and we'll learn about
how to use them and of course I'll take
you through the different categories of
operators present in JavaScript so in
JavaScript there are basically eight
categories into which operators are
divided which are we have arithmetic
operators we have assignment we have
string we have conditional we have
logical bitwise comparison and type of
operator we'll discuss the first three
types in this video that is we'll
discuss the arithmetic operators we'll
discuss the assignment and the string
operators rest we'll talk about in the
following video
first up here is the arithmetic operator
hope you all are aware of the term
arithmetic right
so arithmetic operators perform
mathematical calculations like it
performs addition subtraction
multiplication and division as well so
here are the few operators you can see
on your screen the plus operator minus
asterisk division we have modulus we
have increment we have decrement so
these are the basic arithmetic operator
we'll see each of these operator with an
example so let's move on to the
programming part first so guys I want to
mention one more thing here I want all
of you to make a separate file for each
topic we'll be covering from now on like
for operators you will create a separate
file will create a separate one for
control statements and other topics
we'll cover in future from today so I
want you to create a separate file
because you know in future if you want
to access these topics it will be easy
for you to access those files instead if
you are using a single file for all the
topics it will be quite confusing so
let's start with the arithmetic
operators first let's take two variables
we are in the Javascript file let's take
two variables let's say where x equal
equals to 6
and we'll take another variable let's
say where y equals to
4.
now we'll perform some arithmetic
operations on these two variables we
have already seen the arithmetic
operators present like we have plus
minus we have increment decrement we
have multiplication division so we'll go
through all of these right so let's
start with it here we are done with our
basic three operators which is addition
subtraction and multiplication I have
commented the division because I have
something to tell you about the division
so let's check the output here first let